and when welcome to this video this is a
new three minute madness kicking off
against Katy Perry okay so what is she
up to and any late counter gambit oh my
goodness yeah this is not so bad this
reply ok let's do something funky it is
probably not good night f6 looks like
I'm very much weakened when it's three
minute madness so we shouldn't be so
picky about what's good and what's not
let's try to be aggressive come on Katie
no reply to that night at six looks very
normal okay so she wants to hmm I don't
know what to be honest just get this in
how do i get some attack going here yet
this d3 move fair okay check so I'm out
for Queen 83 m I can well see two hangs
but this hangs as well the only thing is
if she looks the bishop yeah I am hmm
I'm not totally sure that I have a good
move I mean how do I come a situation
i'm trying to say kinky one that's night
f2 that could be tricky okay so Queen
age seven I guess yeah I have to I
basically have two nite see too keen d1
takes I'll take g7 or g 6 i'm taking
just six i think rather okay well here i
can take just sex right threatening made
can you and three minute madness strikes
again lack resigned yeah okay shouldn't
be too critical about this is probably a
game somewhat incorrect by both sides
okay Plotkin don't worry I'll get the F
porn rolling soon enough this is
probably not good right because of t5
and yeah probably yeah this is also
making quite some sense if I take care
that screen age 4 hmm so how do I get
maybe I can somehow play this and now
take here said possible and probably not
g5 I've got 25 that's not a problem it's
probably just not good on ya for normals
96 or something check yeah okay this is
possible but i'm not sure how good that
is you can definitely play that but i'm
not sure that this so scary oops oops
I'm one porn down but well what's a pawn
it's not that much get this going
let's see where the queen is going down
maybe I get even more 10 p 90 for coming
up I need to develop my king side though
okay okay maybe rather take this take
this tempo here this is kind of nice to
get and next I was attacking the rook
okay I try to play with tempe here now
we cannot cancel if he takes rook takes
there's something hanging at least mmm
is he going to Castle lon very like my
rook he has no squares this is a issues
an issue so let's Eva that I get my book
some squares again I a defense as well I
mean defend it's not like i'm having a
super strongest attack ever but I mean
he's doing a good job I think maybe I
should have taken 25 after all 497 hmm
yeah again he's threatening age 6 yeah
doesn't I don't want to but i think i
have to otherwise my rook is just
basically lost and they don't have any
compensation for it if it is slow if it
if it gets lost yeah it's not great as I
said he defended very very well I
believe he's got 95 94 unfortunately and
he's going to go for it the only chance
going for me years I'm playing reason
quickly I don't know this could have
been premature in this push she's not
supporting the porn with that much to
cheek it I want this one I know it's got
a ok I can take you five then so yeah
definitely dangerous Oh with the pod
okay I have a have a passer myself yeah
I thing is I can almost take it this is
just this year which prevents me from
doing it if I had chicken and d7 left
looks dangerous Queenie eight takes
takes yeah I'm actually i'm very ok
downright threatening d8 now 28 with
mate yeah i think he basically has to
play Queenie aid and this is a very good
ending maybe you're winning any time
morning let's check there what happens
if i take on age 3 by the way and we're
not winning this very directly if i take
their what's the deal should work
nice counter can check no here and now
yeah I can go to the seventh and he will
approach with the King so I just have
four against three unfortunately I've
put more time on the clock check check
check check check check ah I was a mouse
lip Jets may check mate so that led to a
maid that mouth slip ok well what was a
becky game not a good one at the start
but somehow for myself back into this or
he he opened the door again um Mary his
ways to to call that game starting goat
buck who's goin bak what to do maybe the
Banco is almost kind of conventional
here for for the madness here maybe I
can do something funky with be five yeah
this one GM your Sheikh he played like a
693 be five against me in five minute
and and and even support the odd one
point I think maybe more than your point
oh ok so I'm getting to winders right or
queen a3 is that the problem nope didn't
go for any of that check you how to take
maybe this one to develop a little bit
so I'm I'm sorry I'm up the pawn
something to drink here that's where
it's not with any alcohol with the three
minute madness sometimes feels like it
like a moment I can only play this kind
of stuff whenever had some at some
alcoholic beverages but it's not the not
the case yep so a six was funky the
position I was unfortunately not that
exciting I have to defend here with have
this poll that I have to defend I can
and I can give him that be three year
and it's good no at this one this I
didn't think was so dangerous maybe
wrongly i don't know i think yeah if he
if he gets the pawn bag and Bishop f6
well my b7 bishop is very bad but may
have six bishop is good teen aged five
maybe yeah
94 and then 94 threatens Knight f6 which
is some problem okay after I can go to F
a ton ok I cannot take the pawn here and
this is where
hmm
hmm how stupid I can't maybe I can I
need to somehow make a mess out of this
ship g5 doesn't work yeah I have to give
this bloody bishop yeah I would like to
do something with g2 of course but he
has covered g5 Quincy five would have
been nice for g2 and d2 but is king at
the Queen 27 what a mess didn't think
about you should avoid or at least I've
got some parts online were not enough
but some it's probably out for rupee hmm
maybe this is not that clear I could
move
I mean why this piece up here
essentially I can take now let's to lose
this takes Queen takes Queen d2 a bishop
here's the problem on a aid yeah I just
lost you can only hope for some kind of
miracle
now you can actually take
check it's not very quick and I'm
definitely going to play anything on
time yet and in three minutes check
check check game drown okay yeah it's
due idiot three minute it's just like
bullet chance of you I really don't
three don't care so much I really regard
five minutes as a different time control
this is such a little bit a little bit
chess already in three minutes just like
dashing out stuff and you can really
play any kind of stuff down as you can
see in the three-minute methods videos
there was a piece down for for nothing
and still white could win because of
yeah no increment no time no nothing
okay come on give me a new game I'm not
quite sure that I did this correctly
here by the way sometimes I'm
accidentally request a five-minute game
simply because I'm more used to that I'm
sorry for the sounds yet my washing
machine sometimes just enormously loud
okay why don't I get a game it's
relatively it's probably not a good time
of day to get games going
yeah I simply don't get a game have to
request our but nobody accepts
game started I am d for Nikki okay so
what can we do and not the Latvian this
is a bit too crazy for my that maybe
this is also not good but not not as bad
as the Latvian he just transposes you
just transposed this to them to the
Schliemann for okay I'm surprised is
that really good i'm thinking i mean my
development is not brilliant but I've
got a pawn and I've got some pretty good
center here maybe lack takes takes 25 is
that the idea maybe maybe it further
delays my development under on the Kings
side yeah now I felt I'm ready for Queen
to and Quinn to be six just get the
Queen off Queen you five I've got Queen
f2 air so check BAM em jack so that's
two points maybe you can take on you for
that's may be possible yep it seems it
is possible but okay let's see etsy I
take this he takes with the rook my
night night I cannot move I can take on
b3 though he will recapture and my night
and I can't cover it then I'd lose it
back so okay this is in fact working so
what's happening here night c5 maybe
next time Wow
amazing this is really absolutely okay
for him he's gotten one pawn back and
he's got 95 common remarkable okay 94 I
guess time morning I people I can play
see if I don't believe this nonsense you
can't believe see play survivor winner
please oh my god you get everything in
here Queen f2 and everything in a new
blonde ale or bagon ahh what kind of
crap I'm sorry he's gotten he can take
on you for yeah this is like the check I
really really food simrock about
sometimes how coincidental chances here
you can take their just like that and
then it's not like he's even having a
good position not like he can play it
somehow he has a good position okay I
don't have to blunder it back
immediately but it's still remarkable
and yeah I can also resign but boy is
frustrating check
check
and this is not really anything serious
but at least have some glimmer of hope
that I can win the beeper on also
whether Jeep one is far too quick
g7 is still a little trap not a
difficult to see one check check okay
black remarkable i mean i don't i don't
really like to analyze those games but
what the heck I mean and that this is
even possible it is really really
amazing yeah now okay maybe this is just
wrong already the engine wants to do
this and black wins yeah probably but
the thing is it didn't it didn't be six
is good here this is what I did not seen
and it should be winning somehow it and
I couldn't figure it out and the way I
played it I was just lost ya amazing
yeah again sorry for the drink sounds or
something with otherwise I could record
it all I mean it's so hot I have to get
some get something to drink okay I don't
get a game again gain started bisous oh
is that grand master Anthony Varrick
okay
he takes only for 96 97 this has paid
off yeah this looks very weird but it's
not so bad actually check okay I'll take
it and so he wants me to go directly
into an ending it seems okay you have
some some quite weird pieces and the
bishop is solid I like it actually take
with the bishop to give it some life
maybe let's do it i mean ii for at some
wood week but getting this Bishop giving
this Bishop some scope is not a bad idea
so here maybe this one
threatened night f7 here and it takes it
check and yeah that's a pretty nice
ending huh I can also just trade routes
not sure that this helps I still have
some good improving moves there should
be five now be windy for very likely ok
let's trade the rope ok I didn't think
about this so much yeah that's the
difficult this is difficult to win if i
take here and yeah it's very difficult
to win and you have to have to play this
a bit differently check check first
let's go over here to f4 check yeah he
always has this one getting into
opposite colored bishops
should projet should draw him it should
be a fortress draw offered draw offered
yeah I can this is just nothing hmm kept
very bad technical play I should have
gotten more than after he blundered he
five yeah but maybe it wasn't such a
good idea to take on d3 with the bishop
the pawn on e4 at the end didn't didn't
prove to be that that important ok yeah
not not really good session yeah I don't
get anything going with my rating but ok
the game before that where you have like
to pawn sir and again styrene f2l
everything XA 1990 something 1994 so
again let's bring the 8th porn yeah this
is a rare continuation but it's not so
bad
yeah I'm not quite sure it I think that
this is not a good idea for white the
idea is well known there's this general
idea of Quincy forward it is usually
played because there's a bishop on c5
and there are technical issues for black
here it just doesn't make much sense I
think you're not going to make me on f7
and all those pieces are and not
particularly well placed what 26 maybe
to e6 ending is very nice for me so why
the ending out I like after the Queen
trade and so it doesn't do that the nice
thing about my position is that d66
those are excellent for controlling the
center threatening 93 now in some cases
ok ok I'll pileup on the FL
yeah so I can't think of taking on g3
it's not completely we completely off
yeah it still doesn't threaten that much
is the thing it doesn't threaten that
much hmm can I get some some more some
more firepower somehow on the other end
what is he playing maybe then I come on
this is 3 minute madness it was a bad
idea to think about that for so long at
the end I was going to do it anyway
objectively speaking of this might be it
might be wrong because it's not so clear
what my threads are ya know some
something on Nate it's really entirely
actually what my threats are ok we're
going to close this for a moment and
then see ya some G a G for actually I
could have played g4 yeah we'll do this
now his screen is unprotected after C
form it took me too long to spot that so
he cannot move the f porn and I'm
threatening g3 here in yo so now g3 or
g3 it's not again not so clear how I
continue after that
I have to be 92 is coming I cover it
with Bishop over to h4 she looks really
strange these goes here okay hmm I just
need the porn on each form that I'm okay
I can establish those two paws I've got
enough here for the piece do need to
check mate here necessarily
I mean checkmate quickly as what I'm
trying to say it's not I don't need an
immediate meeting attack I opens the
position himself check yeah the time
will also be time morning a pretty
substantial issue so what's the deal
Queen here they cannot move this because
my queen hangs row okay hmm that's your
five I can take
white forfeits on time hmm yeah I once
again very strange but even this is what
those games are formed and I'm yeah the
shimmer is not so bad anyway and here d
6 this is not such a bad line they often
go Bishop c5 but this tends to be
tactically tricky with Quincy form and
the six is ok I mean this Bishop is
looking a bit strange on ave but like
still has play on the air foul and so on
it's it's not it's not a bad them a bad
choice at all ok i hope you liked it
thanks for watching